[Musique]
tout le monde lève vos verres au
sénateur Ted Kennedy à la Maison
Blanche en 72
[Musique]
nous sommes une famille il n'y a pas de mot plus important
nous partageons une bombe à vie
[Musique]
nous avons une situation ici sur
Chappaquiddick ça a été un  accident
nous ne pouvons pas trouver Mary Jo
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier soir je
conduisais avez-vous une idée que le tribunal
de l'opinion publique aura votre tête sur
l'état nous disons la vérité ou au moins
notre version de tout vous  sachez que
tous les efforts possibles ont été faits pour la
sauver que faisons-nous pour que le sénateur un
cadavre contienne beaucoup de secrets opposés
peut être la différence entre la culpabilité et l'
innocence dites-vous qu'il y a une
possibilité qu'elle ne l'ait peut-être pas
noyé  J'avais dans ce genre 25
minutes si je recevais l'appel mais personne
n'appelle
[Musique]
parfois chemin vers ta maison il n'y a pas de
bruit le chemin pour choisir ce qui
t'empêche de faire ce choix toi-même
Je ne peux pas qu'as-tu fait ça Ted  vous regardez
Oh s'autodétruire
o  h mon dieu qu'est-ce que je t'ai fait